un référendum d'autodétermination prévu
par l'onu doit avoir lieu depuis
plusieurs années pour laisser le choix à
la population du sahara occidental
l'indépendance ou le rattachement à
rabat mais les négociations menées par
les nations unies impliquant le maroc le
front polisario l'algérie et la
mauritanie sont suspendus depuis mars
une faille dans laquelle les états unis
se sont empressés de s'engouffrer en
reconnaissant la souveraineté marocaine
sur ce territoire contesté une violation
de la charte des nations unies aux
services de l'actuel diplomatie
américaine qui tente de pousser un
maximum de pays arabes à normaliser
leurs relations avec israël
une situation dénoncée avec force par le
mouvement indépendantiste sahraoui
la décision de trump ne change rien à la
nature juridique de la question
sahraouie car la communauté
internationale ne reconnaît pas la
souveraineté du maroc sur le sahara
occidental
elle constitue une violation flagrante
de la charte des nations unies et les
textes fondateurs de l'union africaine
et freine les efforts de la communauté
internationale visant à trouver une
solution pacifique au conflit entre la
république sahraouie et le royaume du
maroc
la russie a elle aussi dénoncé ce
vendredi la décision américaine estimant
qu'elle sort complètement du cadre du
droit international
ce que les américains ont fait ici c'est
une décision unilatérale qui sort
complètement du cadre du droit
international
de son côté le secrétaire général de
l'onu antonio gutiérrez a fait savoir
que la position des nations unies était
inchangé sur le sahara occidental
la solution à cette question peut
toujours être trouvé sur la base des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité
si le polisario soutenu par l'algérie
réclame un référendum
d'autodétermination le maroc qui
contrôlent plus des deux tiers de ce
vaste territoire riche en ressources
naturelles proposé lui un plan
d'autonomie sous sa souveraineté
contrepartie de cette reconnaissance
américaine l'officialisation des
rapports entre rabat et tel aviv un
accord de nouveau conclue sous la
médiation de donald trump le premier
ministre israélien l'a immédiatement
salué j'ai toujours cru que cette
journée historique deviendrait réalité
un jour
j'ai toujours oeuvré pour cela je veux
remercier donald trump pour ses efforts
extraordinaires le ne plus pour avoir
mené la paix en israël et les peuples du
moyen-orient
après les émirats arabes unis le bahreïn
et le soudan le maroc devient le
quatrième pays arabes depuis août
dernier à promettre l'établissement de
relations diplomatiques avec l'état
hébreu